ah this is so exciting my first et
Canada pride of the new decade is with
none other than MS cracker who's on the
phone with me right now hello miss
cracker Polly want a cracker
well some huge news today you're
bringing your one-woman show American
woman to the US this spring but not just
to the US you are coming to Canada how
excited are you to see your fans here in
Canada I'm excited because Canadians are
just like Americans except they can
handle a meet-and-greet nightly so some
manners and like Americans are wild and
Canadian audiences just are so attentive
and loving so I'm excited to take a
break from my fellow Americans and see
the Canadian audiences well I might be a
little biased here but Canadian boys are
also very cute I've heard that but I am
you know just so angelic I wouldn't even
notice yeah I'm so sure all right so you
have to tell me a little bit about
American women which is presented by
five senses reeling in partnership with
tfd presents in Canada so first off that
title says a lot but what is the title
American woman mean to you for me
American woman is sort of about so many
things but I've been going around saying
she's a woman and I realized that if I'm
going to do that I should probably be
paying attention to what's going on in
the world of women right now which is a
call for equal treatment and basically
basic human right yeah so American woman
is all about that realization that you
know if I'm gonna say I'm an American
woman then I have to concern myself with
what's going on with women around the
world I mean it's all comedy because the
thing is I think the best way to treat
serious subjects is with laughter and
like self-reflections
I basically make fun of myself for all
the mistakes I've made as an ally for
women and then yes part of that comedy
is high-powered dance performance for
them to throw in myself all over the
floor like not on beat but you know just
my determination is impressive when
you're doing American woman and there's
you know you're doing the same show kind
of over and over a great year yeah
exactly for years so like as you're
going along this cracker do you ever see
that maybe a joke isn't working and
you're like scratch that I'm adding this
I do a completely different show every
time pretty much because I give myself
topics and then I talked about how I
feel about them that day so it's a
completely different show each time and
I totally get what you're saying it's so
boring
you like repeat yourself so I have to
build that in so that I didn't go crazy
I hope you'll hit on some Canadian news
that's happening once you're in our
beautiful country because there is
there's a lot that you could work with
here in this country as well for sure
I'm actually looking forward to learning
about that on the tour and hearing more
from fans about how they feel about
Canada today yeah I wanted to ask you
something because I've been doing et
Canada pride for maybe about a year now
and you know I get lots of love which is
fantastic but I also get some hate and I
know Ms cracker gets a lot of love miss
Crocker also gets a bit of hate so how
do you deal with that because I know
people say don't read it but I read it
because I feel like sometimes some of
that hate is constructive and it forces
me to kind of look at myself in a
different light is it the same for you I
used to be that way I don't know I don't
even know how to but I used to read it
and I think it was valid criticism and
then I was like well what's more
important my growth or my happiness as a
human being now I don't read positive
things or negative things I don't read
anything anymore and I focus like it's
just between me and the gods of drag
and everyday I ask the drag gods like am
i doing everything I can for drag and
that's all I pay attention to and my mom
my mom says nice day
it's very important to always listen to
your mom that is good advice right there
and I do like what you said though cuz
sometimes you know either good or bad it
can kind of mess with your own mind a
little bit yeah if you read a comment
about someone's that oh she really stuck
the landing on this double pirouette you
like oh my god
people really like that I have to make
sure to do it yeah comment and now I
can't do a double turn anymore because
every time I do it I think about it I
had a lot of traumatic and I just sort
of had like math and now I just care
about calm and people I don't care about
everything being perfect anymore but it
was literally just up until six months
ago that I love you realized oh my gosh
you can't live like this
yeah and now I'm just like I look at it
and braid let's not use is good enough
for rock and roll like are we ready are
we good enough to get out there and show
the kids that means good then let's get
out there and is it isn't that a really
freeing feeling as an artist and creator
to have that mentality now yeah it
really is I mean honestly I want to say
it because I'm so wise but I made that
decision so that's not what it is but
really is it's just I couldn't take it
anymore I was gonna fall apart
so like necessity I was like now I did a
video a few weeks ago naming five Queens
I wanted to see on all-stars five and I
picked you cracker as one of them I know
you can't say if you're on all-stars but
if you're on all-stars five or even
all-stars 26 is crappy ready to kill it
when she walks into that workroom
knowing what she knows now
I feel completely crushed right now this
is not what I came here to show America
the odd thing is that I love all these
politicians because it gave me
everything that I have now I spent like
two years living in that realm and I
kind of want to get back to reality so
that's kind of why things like American
woman yeah because reality and get out
the fans in places like Canada right now
what I want to be doing is bit like
tours like bed alright well thanks for
chatting with me ms cracker make sure
you head to Crocker 2020 comm for all
the info including presale and general
tickets and make sure you sign up for
first access cracker I think I'm gonna
see you right here in person in this
very studio when you're in Toronto and
we are gonna have some fun sound good
all of you guys there can't wait to see
you thanks cracker
[Music]